hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in her often anthologized essay trying
out ones new sword meri Midgley points
out a number of different objections and
I've tallied them up is really falling
into seven different headings that have
to do with the type of ethical or
cultural relativism that she is labeling
as moral isolationism or you know you
could call it cultural isolationism as
well the general idea behind this is
that because we don't really understand
other cultures we can only understand
our own culture we shouldn't make any
sort of judgments about what's
considered right or wrong in those
cultures and she is the example of a
samurai practice trying out one's new
sword by cutting a random person in half
that one would happen to meet after
forging the sword this is something that
there's a word for in the Japanese
language and we say oh that's a terrible
thing but she's saying that the moral
isolationist would say well we don't
really understand Japanese culture so we
should keep our hands off and don't make
any judgments about that and that leads
to a lot of problems and this this is a
relativistic position we could expand it
further and apply these remarks not just
to cultural relativism but to ethical
relativism more broadly where people are
saying listen you don't come from the
same background as me
you're not the same ethnicity you're not
the same gender you haven't endured the
same class struggles or racial struggles
or etc etc etc so therefore you can't
make any judgments about what you know
I'm saying doing going through or you
can't make any judgments about what
those people over there are doing you
know you're not trans so you can't say
anything about the trans community or
practices or things like that just as
one you know particularly timely example
now as I put it out Midgley thinks that
there's some serious problems with
taking this
position the first thing that she points
out is that people from other cultures
don't actually follow this rule of the
cultural anthropologists or the cultural
relativist and they do criticize other
cultures very often quite vociferously
and sometimes you know we even take what
they're saying as being on top of things
or right so she says does the isolating
barrier between cultures work both ways
are people and other cultures equally
unable to criticize us and she brings up
an example of an article in The Guardian
and we could multiply examples like this
where a South American Indian was taken
into a Brazilian town for an operation
it saved his life
when he came back to his village he made
several highly critical remarks about
the white brazilians way of life and she
says they may have well been justified
but the interesting point was that the
anthropologist called these remarks
quote a damning indictment of Western
civilization she says now the the Indian
was in that town for two weeks was he in
a position to deliver a damning
indictment if we're going to say so then
we should be prepared to let other
people deliver damning indictments to
like say Western tourists going and
living in some place for two weeks they
may be off base they may not have enough
of a you know range of experiences they
may have talked to the wrong people but
we shouldn't preclude the very
possibility of making judgments given
that we let other people do that and
other cultures not only make those
judgments about our Western culture late
modern etc urbanized they also make them
about all sorts of other cultures all
you have to do is look through the
literature of history and you will find
almost every single culture being
ethnocentric in that way another point
that she makes is that if we cannot
blame or criticize that also rules out
the very possibility of praising or
justifying so if we want to say that
you know we shouldn't say anything bad
about samurai culture and its
willingness to allow strangers to be
attacked and killed in order to test out
a piece of equipment then we also can't
praise the Japanese for the wonderful
spirituality shown in the tea ceremony
because we equally don't understand that
any more than we would the other customs
so that's an important thing if you if
you want to be able to praise or justify
you have to then also have the
possibility of blaming or criticizing
she says certainly we may need to praise
things which we don't fully understand
we say there's something very good here
but I can't make it out yet this is what
leads us to learn from strangers a third
point that she makes is that if we take
the standpoint of moral isolationism we
became we become unable to even
effectively judge our own culture why in
part because if the the argument here is
we don't understand the practices of
others we don't understand the culture
of others therefore we must not make any
judgments about it there's many things
in our own culture that are rather
obscure or mysterious to us think about
you know traffic foot traffic pedestrian
traffic biking driving around a lot of
the rules seem really arbitrary and
confusing you know we may not have
learned all of them completely how many
of you when you drive have the rules of
the road of your state or country or
whatever it happens to be in your glove
box handy to consult when you need to
when you get to a four-way stop you know
who should go first who has right-of-way
oh if not then you have to be quiet you
can't make any judgments whatsoever well
that's a little ridiculous isn't it
the other thing she points out with this
as well when it comes to judging our own
culture is that if we can't understand
anything about other cultures that makes
it very hard for us to make judgments
about our own because we
other cultures as points of comparison
if we say for example here in the United
States we're still having big debates
about universal health care and whether
whether that will ever be a possibility
or if putting it into practice would be
intolerable tyranny or destroy the
economy if we can't look at you know
other places that do in fact have
universal health care and do quite fine
with it and nobody makes a fuss about it
other than a few blowhards if we can't
look at that and say well it seems to
make sense over there we're unable to
use that as a point of comparison to our
own culture we also can't do that for
things that we think we're getting right
we can't say you know we're actually
doing better when it comes to human
rights than say Russia you know or some
other places so it's important that we'd
be able to judge other cultures if we
want to be able to judge our own culture
she also talks about a sort of
inconsistency of moral judgment that is
involved in moral isolationism and she's
got a really interesting comparison here
she says you know we can no more afford
to put moralizing out of business than
smugglers can afford to abolish custom
regulations the power of moral judgment
is in fact not a luxury not a perverse
indulgence of the self-righteous it is a
necessity when we judge something to be
bad or good better worse than something
else we're taking it as an example to
aim or avoid so why then do we get
worked up about people making judgments
of other cultures for example why do we
not like the ugly American tourists
heading into say a Portuguese cafe and
demanding that the waiter do exactly
what you know somebody at the Olive
Garden would be doing for them right so
she goes in and she says you know what
happens is you know our involvement and
moral isolationism does not flow from
apathy from moral skepticism but from a
rather acute concern about human
hypocrisy and other forms of wickedness
but we polarize that concern around a
few selected moral
Truths were rightly angry with those who
despise a press or steamroll other
cultures we think that doing these
things is actually wrong but here's
where the inconsistency arises this
itself is a moral judgment which we
could not condemn oppression and
insolence if we thought that all our
condemnation were just a trivial local
quirk of our own culture we could do it
still less if we tried to stop judging
altogether so she's not saying that that
you know it's it's not good to stand up
for other cultures particularly against
those who are wrongly criticizing them
but we don't have to accept isolationism
as the means by which we will do that
another thing that she points out is
that if we want to defend another
culture or justify it or appraise it we
do in fact have to have some
understanding of it and she she gives
you this example of somebody who is
justifying
the samurai practice and saying you know
they'll fill in the background make me
understand the custom explaining the
exalted ideals of discipline and
devotion which produced it and go on and
go on and go on she says an objector who
talks like this is implying it is
possible to understand alien customs why
because that is what that person's
action is that's the speech act that
they're engaged in they're trying to get
me to see things their way then again
this could apply not just to different
cultures this could apply to whatever
divisions we want to set up where we say
that you know this is a privileged
epistemological standpoint you from the
outside can't possibly understand it and
participate within it well if you're
going to defend it you're asking
somebody to join in on that standpoint
another interesting objection that she
raises that I think is really on point
is that if we don't apply moral truths
if we don't you know apply what we
actually believe about what is good what
is bad what is wrong what is right if we
don't do that then we're actually
treating other people and other cultures
as
less than human we're not taking them
seriously we're treating them as if
they're lacking something or as if
they're you might say a kind of joke so
that that's a I think that quite a big
problem itself if we want to think that
we're being respectful of other cultures
we have to be willing to apply some sort
of standards that that go between our
culture's and over arch them as well the
last thing that she points out is that
historically this is kind of nonsense
there is no isolating barrier of this
sort if there really was if cultures
could not communicate with each other we
would not have any history at all
because human groups would never have
been able to communicate and interact
successfully with each other and we
wouldn't have the culture that we have
within which cultural relativism could
actually seem like a good thing she says
our culture is know sealed box but a
fertile jungle of different influences
Greek Jewish Roman Norse Celtic and so
forth into it further influences are
still pouring American Indian and
Japanese Jamaican you name it she's
talking from the standpoint of a British
person and she says the moral
isolationist picture of separate
unmixable cultures is unreal people are
talking about British history usually
stressed the value of this fertilising
mix but this is not an odd fact about
Britain except for the very smallest and
most remote all cultures are formed out
of many streams all have the problem of
digesting and assimilating things which
at the start
they do not understand all have the
choice of learning something from this
challenge or alternatively refusing to
learn and fighting it mindlessly instead
if we use the example of Japanese
culture that she began with that is an
incredibly hybrid culture that is still
in the process of assimilating aspects
from other cultures even today so to say
that oh we can't possibly understand the
Japanese standpoint because we're not
Japanese or not you know
somebody to say that Japanese American
not Japanese enough or something along
those lines that's nonsense
every single culture takes in aspects
and elements from other cultures
oftentimes borrowing these things
unconsciously and so there really is no
isolating barrier of the sort that she's
talking about so these are seven main
arguments or objections to this type of
moral isolationism that is often
associated with cultural relativism but
can also apply to other epistemological
positions as well that hold that unless
you belong to a certain group or class
or gender or whatever other designator
you wish to have you cannot possibly
make moral judgments about the practices
beliefs sayings any of those things of
those particular people that's a form of
ethical relativism that's very similar
to cultural relativism treating those
things as if they were cultures and the
moral isolationism that they lead to is
seen now as very problematic for all
these reasons
you